technology has opened up a new era of
entrepreneurship uber and lyft connect
drivers directly with passengers who
need a ride
Airbnb in flip key connect homeowners
with travelers who need a place to stay
Lux will help you park Rover can walk
your dog clink and saucy will bring you
alcohol the sharing economy has enabled
millions of people to access services
that used to be out of reach or didn't
exist but most of these companies are
still based on centralized business
models apps and websites that can be
shut down by regulators or judges on a
whim until now a new company called ob1
has created a blockchain based fully
decentralized online market called open
Bazaar and their goal is to disrupt the
very nature of the one point six
trillion dollar ecommerce industry
itself Obi one CEO is Brian Hoffman a
cyber security expert through up until
recently worked for the government
contractor Booz Allen Hamilton pretty
simply open Bazaar is a online
marketplace that anybody anywhere in the
world can sell anything and you accept
Bitcoin for the payment for those goods
or services open Bazaar is most directly
comparable to eBay or Etsy but it's not
a website it doesn't host product
listings or keep buyers account
information open Bazaar is an open
source peer-to-peer software that users
download and install on their own
computers like a BitTorrent client that
connects buyers directly with sellers
anywhere in the world and because open
Bazaar is peer-to-peer ob1 doesn't have
any control over what is bought or sold
on the platform the idea behind it was
that anything anywhere can be sold and
that really means anything anywhere even
the name open Bazaar it's almost like a
fair
garage sale so to speak and that's the
kind of idea that we want people to come
to the software with and since every
trade is done with Bitcoin there are no
transaction fees for buyers and sellers
using open Bazaar
the major lynchpin for why open Bazaar
is different than those other
marketplaces is that the underlying
payment processing technology is Bitcoin
and so when people sell or buy goods
from each other they do it directly and
they do it for free because there's no
middleman there to take a cut of your
transaction but perhaps the most
intriguing aspect of open Bazaar is the
promise of a truly unsensible
marketplace unlike other e-commerce
platforms like Etsy which doesn't allow
users to list Washington Redskins
merchandise or Walmart which restricts
the sale of parental advisory CDs ob1
puts absolutely no limits on what can be
listed on open Bazaar if we were a bay
and made this decision to allow people
to sell anything anywhere we would be
opening ourselves up to some kind of
legal liability I believe in this case
we're merely providing a software tool
to the masses and each user is deciding
what they do how they participate on the
network so just as someone can write
something very derogatory on a Microsoft
Word document Microsoft is not liable
for that right they provide the tool
it's up to the users the guys at ob one
already know what you're thinking their
product sounds a bit like something
we've seen before we begin with breaking
news tonight a mysterious online
marketplace is shut down by the FBI the
FBI says it has a rested a San Francisco
man who allegedly ran an underground
website for selling drugs documents and
services the biggest criminal trial in
the history of the Internet is over this
morning and so apparently is Ross
Ulbricht freedom ever since
ob1 announced the project a year ago
critics have made comparisons to Ross
Ulbricht ill-fated Bitcoin based
black-market even obi wan's development
history is hard to overlook it started
in 2014 at a Toronto hackathon when a
Bitcoin developer named Amir taki
created an early prototype of the
software called dark market Bitcoin just
like the Internet and all these other
tools it's it's one of these equalizing
technologies that everybody has access
to it
the Bitcoin is is is one of a new set
of technologies based off the blockchain
the blockchain is away for a distributed
group of people to achieve consensus on
a large scale
I think Silk Road had just been shut
down right before this hackathon and so
that was on everybody's minds and he
wanted to prove that the technology
existed to build something that couldn't
be shut down many of us in the Bitcoin
space saw that and I personally reached
out to a mirror to ask him if I could
somehow help the project or at least get
involved somehow his team's response was
that they were not planning on pursuing
the idea that it was just merely a
thought so I did what developers call
fork the project which is basically
clone it and started with a new team
unlike a company that owns an individual
website like Silk Road obi-wan doesn't
maintain servers or host transaction
data for open Bazaar and since the
source code is already publicly
available it's virtually impossible to
shut down the network it is this aspect
of the system the direct interaction
between individual open Bazaar users
free from political oversight that
worries critics who believe the
technology will just empower a new
online black market but Obi Wan isn't
actually interested in the drug trade
they're after something much bigger I
think it's very important to understand
that drug trade it's a very small
minority of things that actually go on
and especially on the Internet while it
may seem amazing that the Silk Road did
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
maybe even a billion dollars worth of
illegal goods a billion dollars is
nothing in terms of how much ecommerce
gets done each year if you know six
months from now open Bazaar is flooded
with just drug listings and new legal
services then most likely it wasn't a
good enough solution for the world's
trade I would consider that failure
because this is more about building a
free market not just an illegal market
you know we all understand what's at
stake in terms of having horrible things
out there on the Internet is not
something that we're working 24/7
bring to the world unfortunately when
you're building something that provides
freedom for users you're welcoming the
bad with the good
you know the internet could have easily
been shut down from the beginning when
people started putting up pornography or
anything else and the government could
have shut that door but is that enough
to say that this should not exist
although ob1 is considering changes that
would make it possible to run open
Bazaar over the anonymous tor network by
default the IP addresses of buyers and
sellers are public that is an ideal for
anyone who wants to sell illegal goods
and services and perusing open Bazaar
you'll mostly find things like comic
books hot sauce
t-shirts musical instruments kitchen
tools watches computers even cookies
this is a sweet express there a store on
the on the marketplace and they sell
these caramel waffle cookies and they're
handmade this guy's based out of Croatia
and he's been a merchant since day one
and he actually sold so many products
that he had to hire some family and
friends to come in and help him bake
these cookies ob1 intends to compete
with the Giants of e-commerce like
Amazon and Alibaba and they've got some
significant support in june 2015 ob1
gained 1 million dollars in seed funding
from Union Square Ventures Andris and
Horowitz and angel investor William Moog
are 135,000 users from around the world
have already downloaded open Bazaar of
course Amazon boasts over 244 million
active users and open bazaars Bitcoin
based platform is a hard sell for people
who see the idea of using a
cryptocurrency as intrinsically
confusing or even dangerous but hoffman
believes that the critics of open Bazaar
will be proven wrong most people in life
don't have an opportunity to build
something that can impact millions of
people on a daily basis if there's an
opportunity to build a tool that you
feel can help many people to do things
in a more free way in a better way and a
more privately in a more secure way
that's something that's very hard
pass up you know if we work hard to
allow users to self-police
to do things legally properly easily
cheaply they will come and rush in and
will overwhelm whatever could possibly
come in from the dark side of the
Internet
you